VTS makes history again with solo
billboard covers plus Frank ocean's new
cover of a classic and holdup Amy
Schumer got married hey guys this is the
daily Denny and it's been a minute since
I've talked about the fellas of BTS I
kind of missed them now BTS covers the
new issue of billboard but get this for
the first time each member gets their
own solo cover RM gets a cover
j-hope gets a cover v jungkook jimin
suga and jin everybody gets a cover and
I think the BTS army can agree that all
of these instantly iconic this is also
the first time BTS has been on the cover
of an American magazine so is a pretty
big deal now inside the mag the boys
open up about their close bond sugar
explains any fights between other
members affects all of them quote if
there's a problem or someone has hurt
feelings we don't just leave it we talk
about it then and there it's all seven
of us and there's a reason BTS has
connected with so many young people
around the world because as fun as their
music sounds it's actually really woke
and speaks to issues involving the
younger generation RM tells Billboard
quote honestly from our standpoint every
day is stressful for our generation it's
hard to get a job it's harder to attend
college now more than ever
adults need to create policies that can
facilitate that overall social change
and when it comes to same sex marriage
Suga simply says there's nothing wrong
everyone is equal their cover story was
actually such a good read so you guys
got to check it out on billboard.com
they give a lot of love to the army as
the group did when I talk to them in
November in case you guys missed my
really fun hangout with BTS or just want
to watch it again or linking the
interview in the description for you
guys now
alright army don't forget the daily Deni
is a new show so we have to talk about
some other stories last time y'all got
confused so this is me warning you or
switching gears now but stick around
because we're talking Frank Ocean who
surprised everyone with a new drop the
angel voice is covering Moon River and
we are officially wrecked
so damn beautiful take a listen
Jason laughter
it's just you're on
[Music]
oh well you got a deuce like that Frank
what's funny is that fans were
apparently so excited about this that
many didn't realize it's not an original
track the song was originally sung by
Audrey Hepburn in Breakfast at Tiffany's
by the way what a treat to wake up to
this morning
speaking of while we were all sleeping
apparently Amy Schumer got married
that's right Amy said I do in a secret
wedding after dating her guy for only a
few months she confirmed the news with
just one word on Instagram yep Amy and
chef Chris Fisher exchanged vows at a
private home in Malibu and he carries
white roses posed with her friend Jay LA
and her dogs and I guess when you know
you know because Amy's romance was real
fast folks she was first spotted with
Chris last November and they were
photographed only a handful of times
this year and they weren't even
Instagram official until this past
Sunday after Amy posted this black and
white PDA pic from Ellen's 60th birthday
now the wedding was swarming with stars
including Jennifer Aniston Chelsea
Handler and j-law and let's just say we
weren't the only ones surprised by the
quickie wedding it was you know very
sudden but it was I mean it was just I
was sobbing those vowels were stunning
that it's just when two people really
love each other and they really mean it
it shows and it's it's it was a
beautiful ceremony and an amazing time
it was great I mean I couldn't be
happier notice my shirt was accidentally
undone the whole time was that was in
every wedding photo no in every wedding
photo all of my buttons were undone it
looks like I was like I was like oh you
thought this was gonna be about you and
I'm the Jennifer Lawrence of my friends
weddings I might be all right guys if
you're still watching this thank you and
if you like what you see give this video
a thumbs up all right I love you mean it
and I'll see you tomorrow for new music
Friday
[Music]